faker isn't happy last week he called
out a chinese pro player for ending one
of his solo q games and now that player
has been punished hard faker has said
that if this kind of behavior continues
he's going to boycott solo queue now i'm
sure we've all said that after a 10 game
lost streak but riot are taking faker's
concerns a lot more seriously
[Music]
this morning i looked at our subscriber
count and noticed we're really close to
2 million subscribers now so if you
still haven't subscribed please do so
like the video and just have a really
nice day
yeah last week the goat to end all goats
faker was having a really rough game on
stream his top laner aatrox was zero and
eight and was refusing to listen to his
teammates in other words
he was kind of running it down reddit
user moonmet translated faker's comments
saying faker was complaining about the
player and said that he would report him
after the game we've all been there
right sometimes you just get an inter in
one of your games but this time things
were slightly different after the game
faker found out that it wasn't just a
random troll his ending toplaner was
xingtian the substitute top laner for
chinese pro team top esports faker then
went on to complain about chinese pros
being given super accounts to play on
the korean server and that if this kind
of thing happened again he would boycott
solo queue until riot fixed things so
this is pretty nuts obviously if i
threatened to stop playing solo queue
because people were entering my games
nobody would give it
even i wouldn't give it but faker is of
course a whole different beast and so
this has gained a lot of attention xing
tien took to weibo to apologize for his
behavior in the game saying it was a
mistake and that he will accept all
punishments from the league and the team
and we didn't have to wait long to see
what those punishments were top esports
put out a statement translated by reddit
user farako grimm which said that they
had spoken to xingtian about his
behavior that they would be cooperating
with the league in their investigation
and that based on the rules they'd be
deducting one month's salary from him as
punishment on twitter eye
crystallization also added that the lpl
had fined xingtian a little over
7900
banned him from the next two competitive
matches and said that he'd been
suspended from using a korean account
until the end of the year now this isn't
the first time we've seen lpl players
being punished through their wallets
last year we reported that v5 player pzx
was fined for accidentally taking
teleport instead of smite in a pro game
the year before famous jungler sofm was
given the same punishment for going afk
in a solo queue game what's not so
common of course are these kinds of
punishments happening because of
accusations made by someone outside of
china by faker himself no less although
many have sympathized with faker's
frustrations his comments did rub some
people up the wrong way he was accused
of racism for seemingly targeting
chinese prose when this kind of thing
happens all over the world and the
korean server has long been known to
have its fair share of griefers who just
give up after an early setback some felt
it was wrong to single out chinese
players but others defended faker saying
that his frustrations lay only with the
specific pros who int not chinese
players or pros in general now this
whole situation kind of reminded me of a
story i covered at the end of 2020 when
faker and other korean pros were having
their games hinted for chinese gambling
sites the thing is the teammates of
those pro players are being contacted by
the betters to intentionally throw their
games the players win big and the
betters win even more believe it or not
people are being paid to throw fakers
games on stream in an effort to stop
that gambling riot korea announced
they'd inspected 10 000 accounts and
suspended the ones they suspected of
being used overseas now obviously that's
not what's happening here nobody is
accusing xing tien of throwing faker's
game for a gambling site but this
incident is another example of friction
between the chinese and korean servers
and some people are wondering why
chinese players pro or otherwise are
able to play on the korean server in the
first place the answer is super accounts
special accounts given to pro players by
riot this is a common thing in regions
around the world but especially so in
korea whose high elo games are famously
of a much higher quality than other
regions chinese pros will play on the
korean server for this very reason to
get proper practice iowa dominate
pointed out on twitter that four of the
top five accounts on the korean server
are owned by chinese pro players in a
statement to a korean media outlet
translated by afk gaming riot career
reportedly said the current state of
affairs is that super accounts are given
to all pro players who have signed a
pledge contract this doesn't just apply
to chinese pro players but pro players
of other overseas regions as well so it
is difficult to consider this matter
solely from the perspective of the
korean office region they also reported
that faker has been talking to the lck
secretariat about the situation it's
obvious that faker is just sick to the
back teeth of having his solo queue
games griefed sure faker isn't raging on
stream or smashing up his keyboard but
as i mentioned earlier in the video he
said that if this kind of thing keeps
happening he's got a boycott solo queue
now this isn't great it's not great for
faker of course but it's not a great
look for riot either the league of
legends goat is publicly saying that his
experience with the game is so bad he
might just not play solo queue so can
riot make solo queue a playable
experience for faker once again well
some have suggested korea having its own
version of north americans champions
queue an isolated invite-only server for
pro players and highly ranked players
now that may help with gambling sites
and people throwing his games for that
but it's not going to stop a pro from
running it down like in this situation
right it's in a tough spot here perhaps
that's why the lpl has come down so hard
on xing tian a two match ban seems fair
a month's salary deducted is pretty
steep but banning him from korean solo
queue until the end of the year
ouch some people feel like he's being
made an example of a warning from riot
that perhaps now more than ever griefing
high elo games like fakers will not go
unpunished
i don't think faker would have wanted
this guy to get punished this hard right
like he's i mean he was more generally
complaining about the situation or what
he sees as like a trend
um
yeah it does seem it does seem quite
steep for this for this guy but like i
say i mean perhaps he's just being made
an example of because
it's difficult to combat this right the
only it's almost like you have to be
preventative you have to stop people
from even thinking about doing it
because
how can you really implement a system
where um
where you where you stop this from
happening when it's like pro players
who are doing it right you have to like
scare them essentially